Hello everybody, hello, hello!
Oh my god, oh I have glasses on, I did not, that was
non-intentional, but I guess it's glasses jokie time.
That was absolutely not intentional.
Anyway guys, alright, let me see.
See if it's the music, okay, or is it too loud?
I always never know about these things, alright.
Alright!
so announcement time tomorrow you know how it says to be
decided streaming time i shall be apparently i just found
out that i shall be participating in the marvel rivals
vtuber tournament um i thought i was out you know yesterday
i gave my final final final decision and they're like are
you sure i was like yes yes i am sure and now they're like
you're back yet i was like I'm bad I guess I wasn't I guess
that wasn't my final final final decision
so I so I guess today I was given a final final final final
decision and that is that I am in the turning minute so uh
so what okay basically I'll be playing tank I'm gonna be
playing I'm off at stake so what happened was that yesterday
i was just like it's just i was like it's just so last
minute and also uh there's a lot you know teams are changing
a lot and i was just like it's just like you know i was just
like uh i think it'd be easier but just drop out like for
balancing wise it just be easier and then i was like uh and
also my manager went to bed so like there was a uh uh one uh
one of my friends was asking was the messenger and they were
like They want to be sure if you're okay, we've done some
new balancing.
Is this okay?
And I was just like, it's just easier if I just drop out as
my final final final decision and they're like, are you
sure?
And I was like, yes, I'm sure.
Like I said I was gonna drop out like three times already.
They're like, are you sure?
I was like, yes, I'm sure.
Like I thought I made, I thought I gave my final decision.
But I guess this is my final final decision that yes, I'm
sure I'm gonna drop out.
I'm gonna tap out of this.
And they're like, are you sure?
I was like, yes.
And I thought they're like, we rebalanced it again.
Are you sure?
And I was like, yes, final, final, final decision.
I will step out.
And then, and then they're like, okay.
And then today they're like, hey, so another player dropped
out and they play tank.
What if, what if you're put on, you play tank instead of
support?
And you'll be considered that.
Elo, like apparently a plat tank dropped out or something,
and then they're like, what if since you, like one of my
friends reached out and was like, hey, so what if you play
as tank, because you don't have any hours on tank, so you
perfectly match that Elo, you can, you can basically be the
plat tank, and I was like, that is true, that is true, I
have no, I have overall, one hour on tank in Marvel rivals,
because I absolutely hate playing tank, on rival that is
true he was right they're like would you want to come back
to the tournament if you get to play if you're on the tank
roll instead on this team and be considered their plat play
and i was just like
well i thought i made my final final final decision but i
guess on my final final final final decision, I guess I
could off-rule last tank.
Don't keep, don't wait.
So by the way, I have to learn how to play tank in 24 hours
and hope to God that I am at least at a plat level on tank
because I don't even know what my My skill level is on tank,
guys.
Yeah, dude, I did not look at my magic already tapped out.
He's like, I'm not dealing with this anymore.
Let's go.
So, after this stream, I have to do a speed run cram session
bootcamp on figuring out how to play tank in 24.
four hours.
Okay, maybe more than that, because it's at 5 p.m.
The tournament sub is at 6 p.m.
tomorrow, but we apparently have to start stream at 5.
So Tank ain't our just sub.
Why do you think Tank is an endangered species?
Do you know in this tournament, there is only two at, wait,
I think there's only three actual tank players in this
tournament.
Everyone else is off-rolling.
there's out of so many vtubers in the world yet there's only
three tank vtubers in na there's only and i have to play
take now
so so i have to figure this shit out i gotta figure it out
within around in 28 hours i gotta figure how to play tank in
rivals uh so yeah that was my final final final final
decision i'm back in it really was i i keep thinking i was
not in because uh i think i said like i was just like no
it's cool it's cool it's just really hard to balance for me
because i am uh celestial support right now okay don't tell
them but i might actually be eternity in like three games i
accidentally sped run to Celestia 1 in two days and I'm like
three games off of eternity I haven't played this game in a
long time I somehow somehow accidentally almost got an
eternity in two days because I had to figure out I had to
play to figure out the meta like it's like riding a guys
it's like riding a bicycle uh no i was you support guys
support i still have not yet touched it because i thought i
was gonna be playing support and then and then i found out
and then you know i was like oh i might not be in the
tournament so i stopped well i still kept playing because
you know when you get the hit you just really couldn't stop
so i was just like you know let's see if i can get to
eternity but like let's see how you get to eternity and see
how fast i can get so I'm like so that's still one right now
like I'm like three games off but I've been playing support
guys I was playing support um um so yeah because I was just
like guys because I was like you know how my initial spiel
was that um you know haven't played rank in so long I'm
around like celestial GM level and then I open up the game
and then I was like no no no I swear to God guys I'm still
low celestial GM level I swear it just I just had a very
lucky win streak chat I just I just happened to have a very
lucky win streak guys and that's why I'm almost at eternity
mr.
broken bond he was super chat thank you thank you here's
some pointers from a solo tank player rank um one uh sorry
rule one sorry Never cry in front of a team.
Rule two, drinking the pain away is the best medicine.
Rule three, your teammates hate you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
Wait.
They're like, can you talk to, can you say hi to your team?
I don't know what.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's see...
Alright, never mind, after.
Okay, they said I could say hi after.
I was just like, I'm streaming right now.
I don't think I can say hi right now.
Uh...
Alright, give me a sec.
New updates.
Oh my god, more people drive down?
what the fuck is all right give me a say
there's more team changes when does it stop what
all right it's all right it's all right everything is okay
i was just like when does when does it stop
Oh my god I'm sad Because after I said yes A support player
dropped out I was like I could have been that support If I
waited If I waited Like a couple of more hours Before I said
yes If I waited A couple more hours
It's crazy.
It's actually crazy.
Like, you want to swap rolls?
You want to swap?
You're not made rolling, bro.
I would do anything to be able to make it.
I wouldn't do anything.
It means...
It means someone else can be taken.
I would do it if it means someone else can be taken, though.
Zaka, thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you, thank you.
And he said, hey, Doki, last money was my birthday.
It's still April, so it counts.
I stopped existing for a bit.
It's either word, but can I get happy belated birthday from
my Kamiya Oshi?
Also, make us tag mains proud for the tournament.
Zekra, to all tag mains, they're going to be watching the
tournament.
Please close your eyes.
Zekra, thank you.
The Akasufa, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Dear Zechra, happy birthday to you.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Wait, please close your eyes when you see me play.
Whenever I alt, look away, turn, click off the tab.
Wait, no, no, don't click off the tab because it means
you're...
Just, just, just, just look away.
Look at your... Look at a different monitor.
outside of the beautiful sky please look away I can't
believe it if I waited four to five more hours before if I
didn't check my messages I could have been able to keep
playing support.
All right.
Anyway, so whatever happens tomorrow, just remember,
overall, I have around one hour on tank overall in Marvel
Rivals.
I know what a, what a crazy, oh, hindsight.
I did, how would I know?
I just asked if I played tank would it be okay for me to
join back and I was like You know what fuck it.
Let's try this out Just like fuck we're doing it live.
Fuck it.
Let's let's try.
We'll see how this goes
Fuck it We wouldn't fucking weeball backfires.
I know.
It was so close.
If I waited three to four hours.
Wait, I think it was even less.
Oh my God, if we waited two hours.
Wait, not even that.
If I waited two hours.
Oh my God, it's not even that.
I just needed to wait one hour.
Sorry, time.
Like, I was so busy the whole morning.
I woke up really early.
And then, like, I didn't realize how slow, how fast time was
passing by.
How slow time was...
Have I just only waited one hour before I gave my response?
I would have been able to play support.
I would have been...
I would have been able to keep playing Subway.
Give us the exact hour.
It's like one hour and 10 to 15 minutes.
If only I just waited a little bit longer.
Just a tiny bit longer.
But don't you take the one time I responded.
in a timely, that's karma.
This is why, this is why you gotta wait.
This only reinforces my work ethic where I respond seven to
eight business days.
This only reinforces that I was right, that I should never
answer things in a timely manner.
Because if I kept waiting, you know what time is to put on
those red, knows this thank you with a super chat thank you
thank you oh that's i can't believe it how could this happen
to me i made my mistakes that's not the real takeaway but
why does that happen huh why
responding to my friend and within a within five minutes i
got punished for it
anyway so i'll be playing tank tomorrow i don't know what
tank we're gonna find out tomorrow i guess we're gonna we're
gonna find out it's gonna be so exciting well i'm finding
out today i have to like a speed run crash course um after
this stream to figure out how what tank i should play and
like at least i have my game sense but positioning is so
different on tank than it is in support so like that's also
um that's also something i'm like i have to learn because i
don't know how to position i don't really know how to
position on on tank in general so uh and like overwatch is
different different compared to rivals because I know a
position in Overwatch on tank but Overwatch is a lot
different when it comes to tanking in rivals because in
Overwatch uh you're just a I just know you're a punching bag
in any game uh no tank tank pull is so hard it's so strong
but it's also I'd rather give my there's apparently a one
above all tank player on the team so i rather let the one
above all player play the one above all i got the only tank
player wait actually no he's not the only tank player but i
got the highest ranked tank player so i rather let him if he
plays tank pool i rather let him play tank pool because tank
pool is so strong and it's best with someone who can play
like it's best with on in someone's hands who is like a tank
player
Oh, NSE, they give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bird, they give a super chat.
You must be properly mowed into tank roll.
You will solo tank with 3D PS1 tricks.
And Madness, Adam, Ultra, Jeff Heels.
Good luck, have fun, Jokey.
They give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, in the end, they're technically, it's like less
pressure on me.
Because then I can be like, I'm on tank.
And as a tank, it's never the tank's fault.
If I die, Where the fuck is my heels?
If nothing's dying, what the fuck is the DPS doing?
Me, I tank.
I already tank.
I am already tanking for you guys.
I've done my job.
I...
I stood there and got beat up.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe stay with Mag, Emma, and Tank will praise pray for it.
in mind to not lose los from supports and you good trust
thank you with a super chat thank you thank you spam gg no
heels when you lose i soak damage what more do you want from
me exactly me yeah i showed up i stood in front of everyone
i did my job i that's all you need from me i stood in front
in the front lines what more can i do for you what so we'll
see how it goes that's actually crazy i can't believe it i
actually waited an hour before i responded i that's like
funny that's actually crazy i literally just needed to wait
an extra hour and then i could have still been
I facetacked me a job done why do I get punished for this oh
yeah anyway my manager told me to look by the way I know I
should be playing game I should be playing the game right
now but also my manager told me to respond to this message
real quick so it's work time that's also why I'm wearing my
glasses I had to do my behind the scenes work real quick uh
yeah sorry I saw something really funny.
All right.
Okay.
Um, all of these work.
All.
All of these work.
They all look good.
All right.
What are, what is all do?
You'll find out one day.
You'll find out.
All right.
Let's see.
Let me double check something real quick.
I'm just double checking stuff.
Give me a sec, guys.
All right, now we boot up Minecraft.
Yay.
Yeah, I'm super excited to get my shit beat up.
I'm super excited to get like CC'd and then what are you
waiting for and then I can't see anything and then and then
20 alts on my screen and then all I can do is just stand
there and take it like a good tank and that's all I can do
and then pray to God that my supports are keeping me up
Foxy.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay, Doki.
I'm going to be there like Roderick from Dyer Wimpy Kid with
Camera watching you take, and then, and then if we, if I
even live for one fight, I'll be like, GG tank diff.
It just, you already sound like a tank main.
It's already, it's already have i'm already immersing myself
in the role right now i'm what's it called when uh when an
actor uh actor goes into their role what's that word called
when they method acting i'm already in i'm already in the
mind of a tank i'm method acting right now i can already
feel it i can't already feel it all right also i hope the
music hasn't been too loud or too quiet but i just need more
higher music let me know all right let's see minecraft oh i
forgot minecraft doesn't minecraft need like i don't
remember if minecraft was window capture oh no it was not
wait it's currently under maintenance not for me i have ad
and privileges all right oh there it okay it's really quiet
all right give me a sec all right bump bump bump um let's
see let me see what do i need to do here i'm boosting up the
music all right let me know hello i'm here now Hello!
Show me parkour world!
I demand to see the parkour world.
Where is it?
Oh, damn.
I forgot the name.
One moment.
What do you mean?
It's in the title.
This waiting room has...
I've been yapping for 30 minutes and you forgot the title of
my parkour world oh my god i am sorry i lost breath like i
lost my breath there because i was yelling a lot it's all
right it doesn't need to be finished i'm just inspecting i'm
the inspector
guys it's all right yeah but yeah i just thought it was
funny i was just
so much Poor timing overall.
But hey, now I'm back in.
I guess I never made it.
And I'd be like, alright, never mind.
I never made a final, final decision until now.
Wait, is that part?
No, that's just a salad dish.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Alright.
What the?
fuck uh it's not this can be like the tallest uh the tallest
diving board like whoa where's the parkour part oh they hit
the world height limit because someone miscalculated Jesus
Funny is the Oh my god This could be the world's Tallest
diving board If we try hard Oh my god we should do that
Alright let's do it Guys Sounds like one of us Alright guys
I have an idea Alright so what we'll do Alright what we'll
do guys give me a put admin admin where are you where my
admin go alright get a water bucket and pour it in this hole
pour the water in this hole alright now let them in let us
have a little bit of fun admin let's see them jump what the
fuck not allowed in my server all right get them all here i
want to see them jump Climb.
Now, climb.
Anyway, you guys want to join the server?
That's right.
Climb.
Tom, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
Keep climbing.
I didn't say fly.
You must climb.
Wait, this guy is so restricted.
What happened to him?
know what happened get out of the pool pools closed get out
or i make you get out
that's right now keep climbing
that's right they wanted to stay restricted i restrict a lot
of people yeah they gotta be specific anyway what's it gonna
say happens a lot what was i saying before i asked i
demanded oh yeah if you guys wanted are curious what this is
this is the doki smp so uh you can join this server and play
with all the other dragoons and me as well by joining the
membership and clicking, oh my god, they're so high up.
Joining the membership and following the instructions,
pinned in the chat.
Guys, follow the instructions, pin on the chat.
And then you too can join the membership.
What the fuck?
Why can't I jump on that?
This is rigged.
oh my god it's shining yes yes oh fell off the ladder oh
never mind he fell off the ladder hey hey oh wait that's the
admin i thought he was cheating oh my god oh wait that's
surprisingly easier than i thought wait how the fuck did he
do it what the fuck
all right that's it hey no cheating all right it's all right
they don't know they just people would think they just
fucked it up
what wait totem boo okay that guy fucked it up real hard
don't worry there's still water down there okay you cheater
i say that's there's no water do they know Alright, fill it
up with water again.
Fill it up with water.
What water.
Someone fill it up.
Alright, bonus points if you can hit this one.
Actually, alright, fill this area with water.
Fill this one with water, guys.
Right here.
I need water right here.
Somebody quick.
Oh, alright, fill up the water right here.
guys okay that's not water I need a fire oh shit wait we
fucked it up guys guys this ain't it what's going on guys
all right fill it up all right now the goal is here oh wait
he still look all right fill it up with water right here
this is the new goal the new goal this would be harder now
All right, is there anyone else up there?
That's still taking their turn?
Amazing.
How are they surviving?
All right.
This is a great parkour course.
All right, we have a new goal.
This is worth 100 points.
This is worth 100 points, guys.
all right right here
it's harder when we're all like around it too they gotta
figure they're like they gotta figure out where the hole is
because we're all surrounding it
another one send me the next goon and they're like where is
it where could the hole be It's like, find the hole.
The hardest game on earth.
Everyone can relate.
Don't you hate it when you can't find the hole.
Aphelion, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
The hole is the goal.
Oh yeah, the ring of fire.
Yeah, make it.
Wait, no, it'll make it easier.
No, no, no.
This will make it easier as a waypoint.
It'll make it easier, guys.
I know.
What if?
I have an idea.
We surround it with blue wool.
Like, we put blue wool around it, so then it's harder to
tell which is the water pit.
All right, does anyone have admin?
We put blue wool around here.
Blue will, so it's harder to find the waterhole.
It's evil.
New game.
It's just find the hole.
Oh, yes.
Wait, is the dark will?
Do we have dark will?
It might be closer in color.
Oh, yes.
Which hole is the waterhole?
Yes, keep climbing.
Keep climbing.
Okay, what the fuck?
This was supposed to be harder.
All right, it's fine.
There you go.
It's fine.
Oh, no, it's here.
They're here.
oh wait nice all the entities are make it day oh wait with
it being nighttime oh wait but they're gonna kill the people
climbing up the ladder yeah prize is you don't die that's
the prize what a wonderful prize you just get to live who's
out who's doing the jump next this is my i can be with this
for the next three hours guys it truly is entertainment for
me what a deal what a what it's so exciting honestly oh shit
not for that guy you did it oh Put it up.
Oh my god.
We have a winner.
Next one.
Fill that hole up.
Oh.
Too bad for that guy.
Fill that hole up.
New hole.
Wait, put it.
Okay, wait.
I have an idea.
New hole.
All right.
Here.
Fill this up.
All right, fill this with water.
That's right, new hole.
And then we'll make fake holes, too.
All right, climb that ladder.
Gotta figure out which hole is the real hole.
Which, oh, wait, and then I'll put, like, there's, like, one
here, too.
So you're like, which hole is it?
It can only be one hole.
But which one's the right hole?
Put the real water in the corner of the hole?
Wait, what do you mean?
Ooh, unlucky for it.
Oh, nobody can tell where the real hole is.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, my God.
That's brilliant.
That is...
Yes, yes, I'm putting the stick to landing.
That should be it on the last parkour level.
You have to be able to land on the right hole.
That's the last level.
land in the right hole it's a to pass the parkour level
nobody has won this level yet that's right oh my god the
hardest the hardest jump for it
Truly the hardest.
Alright, I'll try.
It's my turn.
Why did you just...
Oh.
Watch this.
Oh, wait.
This is actually pretty difficult.
Everyone stand around the fake hole.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
And then the whole change is...
everything the whole changes too maybe like all right you go
first
all right my turn
wee oh
my god i did it i'm so good i'm so good at this oh i'm
Truly, uh, so gifted at parkour and dive boards.
And totally, just a game.
What can I say?
I'm just a gamer, guys.
All right, admin.
What else is being worked on?
Admin.
No, it's all right.
Admin, what else is being worked on on this?
Oh, yeah, make it daytime.
to make the sunshine.
And let there be light.
What do you mean?
I did everything legitimately.
Guys?
What are you guys talking about?
Y'all see me stick that landing?
Oh!
Let's check that out.
Let's check the horse race out.
Look at...
Yo, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
That's a John ass croaky right there.
Croaky Bay.
The croaky, oh my god.
Croaky has his own little town.
Oh, there's Germany.
There's Germany over there.
How am I a bedrock?
All right, I'll make sure I bring the bedrock back.
That's a John ass bird.
All right.
Oh, I remember.
Wait, actually.
Oh, wait, I don't remember this place.
All right, where are the horses?
Oh, there they are.
All right.
It's time to bet.
It's betting time.
There's a button to press it.
Where do you press it?
Oh, is it right here?
All right.
And in the sense, it's low, so have someone low to hold.
course as well push one start race when lamp is all right
someone else handled this someone else pressed this oh my
god fucking course that's the landmark
it's to enable all the gamblers you know is
oh yeah this area oh this is that this place is new all
right We're all in on Red Horse Four I'm all in on four Wait
We can make a pull Bada-dada-dada Bada-dada-dada
How are they running?
Wait, that is so cool Wait, oh my god Oh my god, red horse I
always...
Okay, wait, wait What the fuck?
They can move on their own?
What?
That is so cool!
Wait, who won?
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, is it leashes?
Oh!
Wait, does it change every time?
Wait, press it again.
Press start, guys.
Does it change every time?
Like the winners?
No, I'm pretty sure Red got first or something.
You guys can't guess like me.
I don't know if it changes every time or like oh oh that
horse got bored he's going backwards why is he going
backwards he's drifting okay so it's the same every time
wait how do we change that if it's the same every time
Uh...
Is it the same every time?
He's stalling on it.
He's...
Wait a minute, this is rigged!
This is scripted!
Someone is rigging the horse races.
Someone bet on Polymarket.
I swear to God, if the black horse wins again?
Oh, you can, like, ride him, too.
That's it.
I'm stopping him.
No!
How do I stop this from happening?
Yeah, it is scripted.
This is... I would like to speak to your manager.
This is like the house always wins type deal.
This is scripted.
I demand my money back.
That's fucking right.
What money?
There should be new horses every time.
But that's really cool.
The automatic race thing.
Do not the horse.
Alright.
Start the race.
again guys start the race again do it I'll make sure it's
like it's like that figure skating lady I'll make sure that
horse will never race again oh what what
I can't even cheat properly.
Start the race again.
Start it again.
I'm gonna make sure that's the last race he races.
Again.
There's no way.
I'm
Wait, wait Yes,
yes, we won
We did it justice does prevail chat look at that I told you
Justice does prevail.
I knew it.
We did it, Patrick.
Oh, hey.
Yoink.
Mine now.
Oh, he's so slow.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's explore.
It's all right.
There is justice in this world.
I make my own wins.
Forever.
bedrock he'll never win again that horse will never get the
taste victory retirement forever all right let me oh why did
he stop moving what oh why didn't he want to move anymore
Yeah.
Why does he want to move?
Oh.
Hey,
off to the glue factory.
Oh, you're right.
Since that horse is a loser.
Let me bring that horse somewhere.
Where's the leash?
all right wait what is it called lead right wait what is it
called again
the lead there it is
oh there he is i was like where did he go there
time to take him to a factory wait wait we're all right
which take me to my parkour area let's see if this horse can
do where's the parkour area we're gonna have to don't TP me
I have a horse with me lead me to the parkour area we're
gonna head there Does anyone know?
Fly in the direction.
I'll follow you.
Where is it?
Alright.
Are they flying that direction?
Or are they just flying?
I can't tell.
Does anyone know where the parkour area is?
Alright, he does.
Alright.
We'll follow him.
Let's just assume he knows where he's going.
Okay, I don't think he does.
It's okay.
We can make it.
We can make it, guys.
I have admin privileges.
Keep flying.
Someone fly there and I'll follow along.
You're wasting your rockets, not mine.
All right.
Does anyone know where they're flying to?
Okay, he does.
All right.
He does.
We can get there eventually.
All right.
I think he went that way.
My render skill is not that far.
It's all right.
The horse will make it.
All right.
We're going to have a little show today.
And the best part is that he doesn't have to climb for it.
That's the best part.
He'll have his own special lift.
On top of and see the world.
He gets to see things he's never seen before.
We're giving him...
We're like letting him experience things that no other horse
can experience before.
Also, I lost my tour guide.
Where did he go?
Okay, that way.
Alright, before he disappears.
It's that way.
Alright.
I hope he knows where he's going.
going.
I hope he knows.
Am I going the right way?
I don't know.
Are we going the right way?
All I see is the ocean.
I hope that guy behind me knows where he's going.
facing the sun turn right am i turning right where am i
where am i i see a lot of landmarks over there on my map i
assume that's the right way all right it
has to be this way wait i lost everybody it's you and me,
horse.
Just you and me.
I don't, but I'm just following the bright colors on my
coordinate thing.
Oh my god, 3k more blocks to go.
Guys.
I'm starting to doubt this plan.
I thought, I thought, you know, like 4k away i was like we
can make it i legitimately thought that we've already hit 1k
like it would be like 1k left but guys i don't think i don't
guys it might not look like it it might be longer don't
worry i believe in us we can make it we're so close
Look at us go.
We're flying so fast.
I zoom.
Zoom.
Oh my god.
We're just zooming now.
We're zooming now.
You know I give up.
How do I?
I'm going to
play a new game.
Don't keep moving.
It means I'm trying to figure out how to detach this real
quick.
How do I get this out of here?
Long live the king
Oh, it's too close Oh, I have an idea then Wait
Wait Wait, the lava's got We did it The horse saved everyone
Look at that The horse sacrifices life To fill it up Fill it
up, fill up the lava what a hero what what a hero look at
him he sacrificed his life so that his body can turn the
whole can turn the lava into rock for all the wild animals
what a noble horse he did it for his for the wild animals
living here a Sacrifice worth telling for generations.
All right, wait.
Admin, take me back.
Take me back to the parkour place.
It's time to supervise the build.
As the local supervisor.
TP me back.
All right.
Wait, where is this area?
All right, everyone.
It's time to work.
Get started on the build.
This parkour place won't get finished on its own.
We shall now watch you build.
Come on Chop chop Don't worry I'm doing the hardest job of
them all That's right I brought you all back here Even Do we
get paid?
Even better You pay me So that you can build this parkour
even better
better for who that's right now build build a parkour place
what a maybe
I can ask to add a mod to the server where I get where I'll
get a little whip and go build the parkour arena your bodies
your bodies will build the foundation of parkour mad with
there must be a mod i'm pretty sure there's like a fucking
mod pack or some shit
Yes!
I don't think they're building.
I don't think they know the schematics of it.
Is this even the parkour team?
Like, Pharaoh let my people go.
Only after the place is built.
I've seen the movies.
The Pharaoh at least had his pyramid before he died.
Like,
All right, yes, keep building.
Parkour team is not odd.
I got some scabs to work on it.
It's a lost cause.
Build, you know what, we'll let this team build the first
parkour area.
We'll see what they come up with.
We'll see what they come up with, and then the actual
parkour team can build around it.
Yes, I hired some scabs off of, um, I drove around, I drove
around town and be like, who wants to be paid?
Who wants to pay me to build my parkour world?
And then these are the people I rounded up.
And then after they're done, the actual parkour team, um,
uh, uh, The actual parkour team can build Around this They
can't remove anything That has been built on this land They
have to build around it
So that She can't even walk up What do you think?
I believe No no no they'll build Around the first level It's
like the You know it's like they leave the kids at the
bottom floor in their own play center.
This is the play center for beginners.
It's like the Weenie Hut Jr. This is the Weenie Hut Jr.
Parkour Arena.
You know?
And after they're finished the Weenie Hut Jr. They can go to
the actual parkour area.
Guys, I can I swear I can do this.
I swear I can I can do the one but Guys it's because Guys I
swear I can do it
Guys I swear I can It's because I have creative mode on so
it's harder
Oh oh I did it I touched it
You not see it I touched it
Guys I did it
Guys, I did it Oh my god I hate that
And then Oh my god, I'm doing it Oh my god, I'm so good at
parkour
Oh my god, I'm so good at parkour
Oh my god, I almost did it, guys.
I almost did it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Alright, and then.
Okay.
And then.
No, I...
I fell because I'm doing it legitimately, so you know.
Look at that.
Well, see?
I'm doing it all legitimately, guys.
And then...
All right.
Oh, my God.
It was so good.
Whoa.
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
There's, like, a little jump pad.
Oh, there's a jump pad.
right here let me go bam and i finished the parkour area
let's go i'm so good at this
see i told you i can do parkour i
look at that whoa bam bam Look at that.
Best parkour in the West.
Yeah, see, you saw that Neo jump?
You want to see me do it again?
Yeah, you like that?
You want to see me do that Neo jump again?
Yeah, why you shake your fucking head, huh?
That's right.
it's almost like she's floating oh i know you're all so
jealous guys why are you guys just doing parkour i thought
we were building guys oh i thought you guys were building
not we i'm just a supervisor you see i get paid more to
watch you guys build because i gotta make sure you're you
all you all keep on track you know i'm like the checks and
balances Oh, wee.
You don't need blueprints.
Follow your heart.
There's a completed parkour track.
Yeah, I want to try it.
Is it not this?
Wait, there's another parkour track?
Show me.
Please return to Red Wolf.
All right, someone take me to the parkour track.
Someone TP me.
Oh.
What is this?
These are just houses.
I see.
Wait, is this the park?
Wait, which part is the parkour track?
Like, here?
Wait, where does it start?
Oh, here.
Does it start here?
How do I jump from this, though?
Wait, where does it start?
It's just all parkour.
Oh, it's like Assassin's Creed!
Oh, it starts here!
It's like Assassin's Creed!
Okay.
Wait, how do I change mode again?
Game mode.
Oh, game mode.
Survival.
All right, for one day only.
All right,
oh my God, look at me, go.
I'm so good at this.
No, I have to walk back using my peasant legs.
All right, look at me, go.
Oh my God, how do people do this?
Using their feet to move?
Oh my God.
I can't believe it
What Okay Oh my god I don't understand Is it crouch jump?
It was crouch jump
Alright There we go
all right the need for speed okay
but what if
oh i thought i could i thought there was a staircase up
there i i thought it was a staircase mom she's cheating on
parkour Does anyone have food?
Food for this poor bird.
I need food.
I never starved before.
What is this feeling?
Why does my stomach feel so hungry?
Is this called hunger?
Is that what they called in those stories?
that they tell gods so they would go to bed on time that
is that the stories they tell young gods
is this what it means to be mortal
alright this is it I got this I'm so good at parkour
okay Oh fuck Okay It's fine It's fine We got this
I don't understand Why do my legs not go as fast as your
legs
I thought God created everyone equally And I'm God's
favorite child because I am God oh my god oh did he push me
guys he fucking pushed me I am running he pushed me did you
see that yeah
fuck you what is this red liquid coming out of my no my head
guys why do i feel so dizzy i'm i don't know what that is
i've never experienced that before what is this red stuff
coming out of my my head
they they hit back they hit back what is that word What is
that word you speak of?
Hitting back.
Look at
that.
No!
It's gone.
What a foreign concept.
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
We're doing so well.
All right.
it's okay it's okay we can do this we can do this it's not
as hard as you think it is if a if a peasant can parkour so
can i i have royal blood god chose me because i'm special
look at that i told you i have god's chosen one
We can do this.
She thinks she's Gojo.
I am what Gojo aspires to be.
It's got to her head.
Oh my god.
Oh, I got this.
See, I told you I got this, guys.
Let me go.
Wait, you didn't do this third block.
Why didn't you fully commit to it?
I didn't cheat, guys.
The block was just there.
Access denied for cheating.
What do you mean?
What is that cheating?
What do you mean by that?
You mean God's will?
There's no such thing as cheating here.
It's all God's will.
Hey guys.
God's will.
God's will's gonna show up, right?
God's will
Guys Guys did you see that God don't worry I'm gonna close
my eyes And then God's will Will show up Bring me up I am
God's favorite Oh Thank you God And then when I close my
eyes, God would send, would tell, give me, tell me that I'm
special.
And then when I close my eyes again, and then when I close
my eyes again, I will be transported upwards to this area.
I'm closing my eyes.
I would be...
I think something's happening, guys.
You don't...
I think I'm almost there, everyone.
I think I'm...
Is it done yet?
I did it!
Yay!
Guys, look!
Which way do I go?
Oh, this way.
Woo!
Yay!
Wee!
Where do we go now?
Where does the parkour end?
And where does it start?
Oh.
Oh, this way.
Look at that.
It's okay.
I told you guys.
Everything always works out for Doki.
Yeah.
look at that
oh my god how much more it was there
all right where do we go after that wait wait god's special
powers we're off bye we're up there thank you your favorite
your favorite favorite child a chance to see the end see
guys he's real he's real he's sent in the flood just for me
i told you
He's so, um, I told you he was here.
Oh!
Wait.
Okay.
Wait, wait, I got this.
I got this.
If I close my eyes, he'll send another sign to me.
He'll send another sign to me that I was meant to finish
this course.
Yay!
I'm going to give you an April.
We're doing it, guys.
With the power of God on my side.
I told you.
you look at me yo i'm just a built so different
whoa whoa oh whoa all right there we go the power of anime
whoa whoa i shall close my eyes and then see myself on the
other side as it was foretold where I am special and chosen
oh my god it works I am special non-believers will say she's
cheating wait where am I supposed to go from here wait I'm
actually lost I'm actually lost Did I...
Oh, this way.
I saw the side.
Okay.
Where do I go now?
This way?
Wait, that doesn't seem right?
Oh, wait, no, it's this way.
Okay, that was a- this is a lot longer than I expected it to
be.
Then what?
Where's the next parkour section?
Is it here?
Is it?
Is that it?
Did we make it?
Did we win?
Wait, did we win?
Oh, the reward is the view.
Oh my god, look at that, guys.
I told you.
Easiest parkour of my life.
Oh my god.
Fucking easy.
Let me put this here.
I can't play science here.
Too easy.
Please make it a real challenge.
Two out of ten.
I gave an extra one point just for effort, you know?
effort yeah you tell them don't get I know it was too easy I
just I didn't even sweat at all honestly after I figured it
out in the first area after I figured out in the first area
everything just was just way too easy it just all came
together it's such a hard IGN 200 600 10 I don't need to
sign it it's blessed by It's blessed by my hands.
All right, and Moan.
It was nice to walk with the people down there for a second.
To walk amongst the commoners for a second.
On the third day, she has risen.
The walk amongst mere mortals.
It was nice to see what it was like.
What it was like down there.
Pretty easy.
Not gonna lie.
Being a mortal was so easy.
Honestly, it's like a walk in the park.
Or you could say a jump in the park.
honestly pretty easy this parkour section could have been a
little harder to be fair didn't really feel like a challenge
at all this grand toky please alright admin take me a new
place no worries poker crap you know it was good effort plus
one point for effort though plus one for effort you know all
right adamant take me to a new place but i haven't seen yet
what is this
this may look familiar this is a prison
Why is there a prison here?
Why did you make...
Is it cops and robbers?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Lock her up.
Oh, one of the most popular, well-known Minecraft builds.
Oh, I just thought it was...
You know what I thought?
I thought it was the G-Mod Prison Break.
Oh, so that's what it is.
I didn't watch a lot of Minecraft videos.
I'm sorry.
I watched Gmod videos instead.
While others were watching Minecraft builds, I was watching
Gmod shit.
I was watching Troubling Terrorist Town, Prison Break, Death
Run.
Instead of Minecraft builds.
And also Treetopia.
Also Creature Hub.
creature hub and tree topia creature like or the minecraft
stuff oh yeah can you take off my jump boost i don't know
how to get that off of me
oh yeah show me the other popular build also can you remove
remove the jump thing it's messing me up what was this build
someone educate me on minecraft lore what was this build
about
what is this what
is this is this an arena see what's this no way the Coliseum
wait what is this the arena wait what is this oh
it's a popular MMO arena a lot of things happen in that
place mom versus mom videos oh that's cool oh so it's like
but hers not she's just confused i didn't grow up well well
i just didn't play minecraft a lot growing up i just played
g mine because i was just like for me i was just like i felt
like i wasn't creative enough to play I sort of avoided it
because I was just like I don't know what to do in Minecraft
you know you can do anything in Minecraft so I just never
never really grew up with Minecraft in general I literally
the only Minecraft videos I watched growing up was literally
from the creatures and uh from uber hacks or nova and Alex
HD yeah we know you've seen your builds so like I I I think
the first time i've ever played minecraft um like actually
played it played it was was like i think when i was in court
no when oh uh when i started my own server years ago that
was when i've actually played minecraft for the first time
like the very the while i was creating my maze of doors uh
when i was creating like uh the door maze that i made that
was the first time real and then uh and that was my very
first build
it wasn't really a maze it was it was just one area you just
go through it the hallway sorry the door hallway that was my
first and only actual build i've done the others i just that
was from my heart the other builds i've done in the past
like in the past after that was just me Oops, all doors.
I mean, what kind of mods do you want us to add in?
I'm down for whatever.
Oh.
Oh, it's the TCG stuff.
Oh, that is so cool.
Oh, my God.
It's all the cards you guys added.
I'm down.
You guys just got to be like, it's your server.
like uh oh you just gotta uh just agree on what mods you
want to add ultra rare drag oh that's cute it's all of you
guys the rare dragon cards oh my guess i like little
portraits and stuff too
but you guys all uh fully added a couple things are bro
about get but you guys all want to um add anything specific
to the server you're welcome to do that as long as all of
like not all of you Because I don't, I think one person
would be like, one person would be like, I don't agree.
So, as long as majority are fine with it, then that's okay
with me.
Deb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think I sort of just never got, never was in the
Minecraft, like, rabbit hole in general.
Because of that.
Because I was just like, oh.
not that creative and block game so I don't know what to do
every time like every time I have a friend that wanted me to
play more block game like vanilla block game I just be like
I would just like make a farm and then and then that's it I
make a farm and I'm like yep I did my job.
I tend to my farm.
I'm like Thanos after he accomplished everything.
He's like, that's all I do.
Just working hard on my farm.
It ain't much, but it's honest work.
Oh, that's so cool.
There's like the whole arena for it too.
Can we like watch people battle it?
I won't watch a battle Alright Someone Challenged each other
Oh my god It's like I'm watching Yu-Gi-Oh right now Sorry
they give us super chat Thank you thank you Oh my god It's
like I'm watching a live Yu-Gi-Oh battle
Funded by Sero Kaiba Oh my god I feel like I'm Pegasus At
the moment At the Like, what was it?
Like, the fucking goddamn competition he hosted for, like,
$1 million.
It's time to duel!
Let the best deck win!
And then if you lose, you get sent to the Shadow Realm.
The Duelist Island.
Welcome to Duelist Island!
For a chance to win.
$1 million!
in cards all
right who shall challenge nobody wants the challenge quill
who shall challenge
quill you guys hear about uh some guy in best buy guy i
don't know why i showed up on my news feed on my twitter
feed but some guy in best buy was trying to like uh sneak
into best buy uh to be first in line for some new Pokemon
card release.
I lost track.
I was like, what new Pokemon card?
I feel like any Pokemon card release, people are going to
try and scalp and line up for it, but there was a guy that
literally, like, hid inside a Best Buy bag to be, like,
first in line for it.
That's why.
Loser gets to be trapped in my card.
Whose soul gets trapped in it forever.
For only one
only one person wants to challenge well what are you scared
that's it I'm nominating someone you there I don't know if
you know how to play the game but I'm sending you to do this
island oh oh that's awkward well
Alright, Oro Owl versus Quill on Dueless Island, who will
win?
Who shall be sent to the Shadow Realm?
And who shall advance and win a million dollars in cards?
All right.
They got sent to the shadow realm.
Is it working now?
This is a little confusing, guys.
I can't even tell if they're playing it.
Are they dueling?
Are they dueling, chat?
Are they, are they?
Are they, guys, are they dueling?
Is it happening right now?
Are they doing it?
Yeah, we're the holographic monsters.
Hello?
Where did the budget go?
Maybe.
This game is pretty so please be patient.
What do you mean?
I've seen the Yu-Gi-Oh videos.
It's like two turns and he's out.
has anyone summoned the blue eyes white dragon yet maybe
it's really tiny and we can't see don't worry don't worry in
20 more episodes they're gonna place their first card guys
in 20 more I don't know in 20 more episodes it's gonna
happen all It's time.
The door.
Okay.
Did he place a card?
He placed a card and then he pressed a button and it lighted
up.
the thing is lighting up now.
Oh.
Wait.
Music is playing now.
Oh.
This guy...
Alright!
Oh, that's insane!
Play!
He placed it!
What the fuck did he place?
Wait, what's the zoom in button?
BOM!
Guys, how do I zoom in again?
I don't remember.
What a play!
Quail placed a green card.
Oh, it's definitely not Z.
Oh, I don't have it.
And then she...
Ora rotated her card.
And then the green shulker box came out.
And then 260 HP.
Orange shulker box.
280.
Is this a manual thing or automatic?
Why do we have this guy placing the tiles?
What?
Wait, I don't know Wait, I...
He swapped to attack mode!
And then...
Oh, it's manual, it's like the tennis...
The tennis boys where one guy goes up to pick up the tennis
balls, this guy goes up to fucking swap cards.
It's still my turn.
Oh, the turn took so long that the music stopped guys.
Oh, yeah, there we go He placed call me goon and use art of
goons I might need to wash from below.
I got beat Is he like the referee?
Oh, oh, oh The music's getting intense.
I have no idea Nothing is happening!
Oh my god, Owl placed Thorin in attack mode.
And he, she won?
What does the power do?
Did you lose?
This button.
Oh, the music is cool.
Quail used!
Alright, what else?
Huge play, I don't know what's happening.
Refused!
Slime block!
I have no idea what that means.
Line block is now in play.
And it's splash potion.
A poison shows up.
Guys, this game might be confusing.
This game may or may not be confusing, chat.
Oh, I'm so confused.
Quill!
Oh, oh!
250 HP!
What happened?
Just like modern Yu-Gi-Oh.
Yeah, by modern Yu-Gi-Oh, the game will be over by now.
Bum-Bum-Bum-Bum.
Bum-Bum-Bum.
Oh yeah.
Bum-Bum.
All right guys.
I'll come back.
I'll come back next month and then maybe the card game will
be over.
I'll come back next month and then maybe the match will be
over by now.
Joki, come back.
I can't finish my dinner before first turn.
Next month is soon.
All right, does he made a turn?
What was your turn?
And what did you guys do?
Or I'll use this item!
What does that do?
Quail is thinking.
He has the eight card.
That's it!
Send both of them to the shadow realm.
I'm done.
This is also why I don't play card games.
That's it.
Take me to the nether.
Admin.
Right now.
That was an intense game.
Your god.
Your god is now born.
I required.
Substitance.
Man, admin, I demand the TP to nether.
That's right.
Oh, that's not it.
What the fuck?
Where is the nether?
What?
Alright.
Actually, admin, take me to the ender.
That feels more right.
I don't know how I got confused with Nether and Ender.
Take me to the Ender.
I don't know what you expected.
Alright.
It's gotta wait for the TP for my fast travel.
It's time to go to the end.
oh yeah the fucking what is it called the terraformed the
terraformed end
it's time to send you To the shadow world!
Oh.
Well then.
That.
Alright, the other guy didn't have a...
The other guy didn't have it, so we're fine.
Oh wait, he did.
They escaped the shot.
They escaped from the millennial eye.
Oh, well then.
Oh, well.
Oh, then.
I did not expect that.
I forgot that everyone has.
Everyone has a...
I don't get home.
Well played, a dragon.
I forgot that everyone has, uh,
what are they called again?
Electra's.
How do I get home?
Oh, here it is.
I'm back home now.
Where does this take me?
Oh, it's back here in the arena.
Oh, teleport.
Oh, never mind.
They teleported me.
All right.
admin take me back to the to a parkour world oh that's cute
i don't think remember seeing this the fishing they're
fishing oh that's cute all right take me back to parkour
world
but if you guys enjoy the server so far you guys enjoy the
server so far Um, please, you can join, any member goons can
join the server right now.
Just click on the link, paste, pin, and chat for the
instructions on how to join our SMP.
Alright.
One last.
Wait.
Oh, I lost my stick.
Oh, wait, no.
What was over here?
I lost something.
I don't remember what I lost I had something I was holding
Put the water right here Admin Put the water oh it's a
spyglass Okay actually I can do it I'm gonna look at me go
I'm so independent See See Like, let me go.
All right.
One last dive for the road.
Climb.
One last jump before we got it today.
And then I have to do a speed one crash course on Tank.
We've come a long way.
way oh i do not think they're landing on that for real now i
you might need to park this somewhere else guys you might
have to park this i don't think you can yeah i don't think
they can land on oh
sorry all right dive park our dive board had like cows
passing by Oh, that's awkward.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for watching today's stream.
Tomorrow, there will be a Mabo Rival stream.
It'll be on YouTube, not on Twitch for this year one, right?
It starts at...
The tournament starts at 6, but we have to be live on 5, and
I shall be playing tank.
So it's going to be a wild, wild ride.
A wild tank ride.
all right let's see how it goes chat one hour on a tank
overall it's gonna be exciting
i don't even know what tank i'll be playing for tomorrow so
we'll see we'll all be surprised tomorrow guys on how that's
gonna go um i don't think i'm winning again for this this
tournament
would honestly would rather just play i would play dps all
right hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check yep and move around to get that blood flowing and if
you used it for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see
you guys i'll see you guys later everybody bye guys bye